again I'm just asking you if based on
the numbers more Germans died than Brits
in World War II did that mean that
British the British were wrong in World
War II because they did many more
Germans side than Brits based on the
numbers that mean that Britain was wrong
in World War II Britain wasn't bombing
civilian
[Applause]
civilians you should talk to the people
Dres but you can't cuz
they're now they hit Dresden hardest of
all I believe that's what they call Base
Ben Shapiro I'm Dave Ruben this is the
Ruben report it's November 9th 2023
we're live streaming on Rumble locals
and YouTube Share subscribe tap that
notification Bell if you have not we are
doing a Ruben report Community Q&A after
I hit up a couple stories involving
Douglas Murray Jordan Peterson and
Thomas Soul were giving you the big
three today uh but if you want to join
us for the postgame show after you can
at Ruben report.
locals.com and you might notice our set
is a little more blue today we tested
something out last night during our post
debate show it was our evening setup
there was some tequila behind me the
lighting was a little different and
people said to me they said Dave the
color scheme we like it we like the blue
Connor can you flip the oh my God look
at us we have blue lights now and we'll
test them out we're just going to see it
feels a little warmer to me a little a
little it's warmer and cooler which is
an interesting combination uh Phoenix is
telling me it looks like Ozark it looks
like a show called Ozark I don't know
exactly what that means I know Ozark's a
show I guess it looks like Ozark okay
we'll take it uh anyway uh we're diving
back into the Israel stuff today because
obviously uh this issue is not going
anywhere Israel has a lot of work to do
to clean up Gaza uh but I want to focus
more today on sort of the reaction of
the last month not exactly what's going
on on the ground in Israel although
Douglas Murray is in Israel he's on the
the Gaza border right now and doing some
great reporting from there which we'll
get to in a second but really this this
absolutely insane reaction that we have
seen largely on college campuses and in
our cities not just here in the United
States in New York and Chicago and Los
Angeles violent riots often
but also of course in London and in
Brussels and in Paris and all over the
place and how bizarre it is that 1500
Jews get brutally
murdered raped burned all of the stuff
uh and the world reaction or at least a
large part of the world reaction seems
to be oh let's just kill some more Jews
how about another 8 mil and then we'll
see what's what so we're going to get
some analysis from Douglas from Jordan
and from Thomas soul and then a
community Q&A before we do it let's talk
about oh you know real quick I should
just mention so we did our postgame show
uh last night the debate was in Miami my
general sense which is why we're not
going to cover it again today it was
just sort of a push for everybody VC had
probably the most viral moments of it
for sure when he really was uh hitting
Nikki specifically Dan santis did the
usual Dan santis stuff it's all good
it's true but no like major viral
moments Christy and Tim Scott it's not
much of anything and Nikki it's sort of
if you like her zingers when she goes
back and forth with uh Vette then you're
kind of there but again it all relates
back to Trump and he was not there and
you know I just at the end of the day
whether you like Trump to santis VC or
anybody else I do not think it is good
for democracy if candidates will not
debate because what will end up
happening is someone will become the
Republican nominee one way or another
whether it's Trump or Dan santis or
whoever and then eventually the
Democrats will just be like well you
know the Republicans didn't even really
debate each other and Biden will come up
with a way that he doesn't have to to
debate Trump Trump's got too many white
supremacists I'm not even going to
debate him there's such a bunch of
racist those Republicans we're not even
going to debate and then we will have no
debates and you may think that the
debates are all farsal and they're old
and the Machinery around them and the
cable news aspect around them is is not
good and it's not insightful and you'd
be right but if we do not have any
public debate about any of these issues
man it will all just get worse and
doesn't it feel like it's kind of all
designed to go that way so we need to
debate these things also I'm being told
that Tim Scott's girlfriend was not uh
seen on venue so we still don't know
where she is any who let's talk about
Field of Greens and then we'll get to it
guys Field of Greens is the healthiest
thing I do every day I actually really
love this stuff I wouldn't want to live
without it this is nutrition the way
nature intended once after after I
started taking fi of greens I had way
more energy throughout the day look at
my skin and my hair come on it's looking
good and I just started feeling
healthier overall Field of Greens is
radically different each organic fruit
and vegetable was medically chosen to
support heart and vital organ health and
with flu season here I Trust Field the
greens to keep me healthy I promise
you're going to love this product but if
for any reason you don't they'll give
you 100% money back guarantee I got you
15% off your first order and free Rush
shipping visit fieldof greens.com use
promo code Dave that's field ofg
greens.com promo code Dave and now back
to me okay so let's uh dive into again I
want to focus more on the reaction the
sort of world wide reaction these
protests the calls for Palestine to be
free from The River To The Sea which of
course is a call for genocide the
violent protests out there I have no
problem calling them Pro Hamas protests
because there are no people out there
saying oh Hamas is bad these people are
celebrating the actions of Hamas okay it
is that is just clear and it is a fact
if you can find me videos of people at
Pro Palestine rallies that are going you
know Hamas really are bad guys no
they're the ones that in instigated and
inspired all these lunatics to be out on
the streets anyway Douglas Murray went
on Piers Morgan last night and Piers
look I've done his show he's been on
television forever he has a way of
taking every position all the time and
also taking no positions and Douglas is
just clear clean and and I would say
over the last month has basically been
the best voice when it comes to moral
Clarity on what's going on here take a
look difference isn't there well there
is but I don't think that all of these
protesters are pro Hamas and the
difference the difference is you have a
large artillery behind yeah but you
wouldn't you don't honestly think
they're all pramas these
people well I I I think that anyone who
for instance chance things like from the
river to the sea is is in fact yes but
they're not all doing that or is
criminally ignorant oh well they are I
mean there's masses of videos of them
marching past West winster Abby last
week saying exactly that yeah but
they're not all do past s Winston Church
watch the videos and there are lots of
people and some who aren't well here's a
challenge okay well here's a challenge
Pi if if you decided to go on some kind
of March and in week one you discovered
that you had the BNP along your side
calling for instance for the murder of
all black people would you not wonder
whether or not you should go on week two
and would you not drop out by about week
three I'd have thought so I would that's
a good question uh and yes I
would don't worry ladies and gentlemen
yes it is a good question because I get
it Pi you're playing Devil's Advocate
you want to appear to be objective or
something like that but Douglas is
completely right is it true that uh well
let's say here I'll give I'm going to
give Pi Morgan every benefit of the
doubt here is it true that not every
single person at these rallies is
chanting from The River To The Sea well
of course that is true right there are
some people who probably don't scream it
while everyone else is screaming it but
then Douglas lays out the truth if a
bunch of people that you're marching
with day after day after day keep
screaming kill all those people and you
just don't scream are you much better
than them so Douglas just absolutely
gets it and he pins peers into having to
say what obviously is true uh they then
ramped it up a little bit more because
uh the next step in what's going on here
uh is that the limits of liberalism are
being reached the limits of free speech
if you are going to allow a group of
people to call for genocide not only for
Citizens you know halfway across the
world but for your own citizens in your
in your country cuz when you call for
the death of all zionists basically
every Jew believes that the state of
Israel should exist and by the way it's
not just Jews virtually every Christian
believes that the state of Israel should
just exist and okay all that stuff
anyway they got into it about uh Free
Speech relative to these protests we've
been at a center of allowing these
people to be in our country and indeed
to plot Terror from our country for
years so it's always a bit Rich to hear
the British I think uh lecturing others
about being an unsound part of of the
International Security uh community as
for the actual marches look um I'm
afraid that the rules on this are very
very clear um you are not allowed to
glorify Terror or call for Terror on the
streets of Britain and that existed
before the 2006 terrorism act banned
glorification and it certainly exists
now uh if you stand on the Streets of
London Calling for Jihad you are calling
for Terror and that is actually a place
where free speech is at its limit and is
no longer permissible it's the same with
for instance calls for inada on the
London tubes remember we had a touch of
in on the London tubes a few years ago
so again calling for in is something
that you're not allowed to do in the UK
for murder you're not allow you're not
allowed to let me finish one other case
you're not allowed uh to stand on the
Streets of London and call for the
murder of Jews or any other minority and
yet people have been getting away with
this Saturday after Saturday and and and
are the police arresting people no no
they're not the police last week said
we're outnumbered all right again we
could have played the full clip it's a
lot of butts and pauses from peers that
he wants to appear objective I'm not
bashing peers again I've been on the
show sure he's not a horrible human
being but this this thing where they do
this moral equivalence do you want to
live in a society and this is what
Liberals are now going to have to figure
out liberals who are generally the old
school liberal tradition ACLU allowing
neo-nazis to march in skoki Illinois in
1972 uh to express their freedom of
speech and that's what that was the
liberal position back then but that is
fundamentally different from where we
are at now where hundreds of thousands
of people are out on the street who have
been misinformed and and their the
education system and the cultural
attache has completely failed them so
that they think Up Is Down and good guys
are bad guys and they're celebrating
this medieval barbarism and all of that
stuff when they start calling for Jihad
that is calling for violence when you
say River to the Sea it is calling for
genocide when you target Jewish
businesses or you go to specifically
plac places where you know Jews or
Israelis are what should a liberal
Society do at that point we that is the
precarious spot that we are at right now
and last week when I was in London
having driven by a Hamas protest right
by it it was not that comfortable to be
quite honest uh I asked it was I was
actually on my way to the ark Forum uh
and I asked Douglas Murray what do you
do when
liberalism sort of gets to the end of
the road we have uh people on our
streets jihadists and their fellow
Travelers calling for the murder of
Jewish people the destruction of the
Jewish State and the destruction of the
British State well I say in that
situation we can remain hand ringing
liberals about this and say as some let
us say not to be too rude Centrist dads
do in some of our newspapers that we
must simply ring our hands at this and
say this is one of the prices we must
pay to remain a liberal society and I
say screw that okay so Douglas is making
his thoughts on this and his feelings on
this very very clear and the UK does
have laws about supporting a terrorist
organization and glorifying terrorism as
he said earlier so what do you do the
question is if you live in London right
now if you live in Paris if you live in
Brussels or Amsterdam where they have
similar laws to all of these things
right they don't exactly have the First
Amendment protections that we have here
and by the way there are things that we
can do here
such as what Ronda santis has done in
Florida if you offer material support
say fund raise for these Hamas
organizations we're going to kick you
out of our campuses and things of that
nature but what are these liberal
societies going to do I suspect
unfortunately for my friend Douglas that
they are not going to do much I I don't
think that the people of Britain and the
people of France and and Holland and
Brussels uh Belgium will will do much of
anything I think they will complain
about it sort of uh but will they get
the police out there and will they
protect their minorities but it's not
even just protecting their minorities
will they protect the very ideals that
make Britain Britain and France France
Etc I'm not so sure that they will I'm
not so sure that we will do it here but
we better start thinking about it
because this ain't about the Jews when
they are done with the Jews as I keep
saying do you think they're going to
wash their hands of this whole thing or
will their lips and their mouths be
salivating right and going holy cow game
on let's do it uh and the reason for
that is that Jews are the Canary and the
coal mine as a minority that succeeds a
good Society likes that we are veering
into this place where we have made it so
that if you are a minority and you
succeed the system doesn't know what to
do with you this isn't really about the
Jews this is about the ability for
societies to have pluralistic views and
people of all walks of life actually
attain their dreams and the Jews don't
fit in in that intersectional calculator
as you know want to show you one more
from Piers Morgan because Jordan
Peterson was on uh this is during the
ark conference just uh last week uh and
Piers asked Jordan about the growing
tide of
anti-Semitism where were you when you
first heard about it and what was your
instant feeling about
it well my instant feeling was to be
sickened by it I'm also more sensitive
to any signs of anti-Semitic catastrophe
from
studying the Holocaust for the length of
time that I did and I've always regarded
Jews as the canary and the coal mine and
I think the reason that the Jews are the
Canary and the coal mine is because
they're a successful minority you know
and if if a culture can tolerate a
successful minority it's pretty damn
robust and it's not very resentful and
as soon as a culture starts to get
resentful that Jews make an easy target
because they're a minority and so that's
an easy target to begin with but then
they're the minority that has the tarity
to be successful that really brings the
resentful out of the Rat holes they're a
minority that has the temerity to be
successful that that is what the uh the
American dream is all about again this
is not about Jews you watching this
right now you're most likely a minority
in one way or another in even if you are
white right like you can't your
ancestors came here it's not I don't
mean minority in like the most narrow
view of it but everyone watching this
you're ancestors basically came here
with nothing and then they probably
worked a lot harder than you have to
work right now just really think in your
own mind for yourself try to think about
uh your parents and your grandparents
and your great-grandparents however many
generations ago your people got here and
no one gave anyone anything certain
minorities were able to figure out how
to succeed within that system be it
through uh culture or tradition or
religion or belief or any of those
things and that's what the American
dream is all about so when they go after
the Jews now the canary and the coal
mine line that Jordan's using is correct
it's just it's not going to end with
them they're the ones going guys there's
noxious poison in this coal mine and if
the canary drops dead a whole bunch of
us are going to drop dead all along uh
all alongside that Canary so everyone
has to care about this and we have to
figure out what will be those limits
that Douglas is talking about about Li
with liberal Society will liberal
societies die on The Sword of free
speech for everybody to the point of you
can call for the death of your
co-citizens
for you know for hundreds of years is
that the liberalism of the
Enlightenment I don't know maybe it is
if societies won't do anything in the
face of all this stuff but I want to
show you one other thing since we've
done Douglas Murray and we've done
Jordan Peterson how about I give you the
trifecta of Sanity uh this is a video of
Thomas Soul this is from probably 2025
years ago uh Thomas Soul being asked
about why anti-Semitism is so prevalent
in history you have u a chapter that's
the first chapter is black rednecks and
white liberals the second chapter is are
Jews generic why the jump to from black
rednecks and white liberals to our Jews
generic what's the point well this book
is a really about ethnic and cultural
issues in general so there's a chapter
on the Jews a chapter on the Germans and
then there's a chapter on history in
general so that that's uh they they're
lumped together because they're all
cultural ethnic issues fascinating story
because among the the the middleman
minorities of which the Jews are the
most prominent uh the hostility of these
people in countries around the world is
out of all proportion to that to any
other kind of group I can think of uh in
terms of violence uh the vi the number
of uh of BL the number of Chinese killed
let's say in one year uh and by mob
action exceeds all the blacks lynched in
the entire history of the United States
and the number of Armenians killed in in
Turkey you know during the first world
war is greater than that and of course
the number of Jews slaughtered on a
number of occasions in history even
before the Holocaust is greater than
that so that the question is why this
particular kind of people are the
targets of so much us venomous hatred
and I think the answer is that that um
they not they not only succeed they
succeed in a way which is a threat to
the egos of other people but the guy who
comes here let's say from Vietnam or
Korea and arrives here with little more
than the clothes in his back and a few
broken words of broken English uh and a
decade later he has his own little
business and you see his son few years
after that getting ready to go off to
harbit or MIT you got to ask yourself
you either got to you know you you you
you've got to hate yourself for saying
my God I I've been stagnating this guy
was nothing and now he's ring up or
you're going to have to hate him years
ago one official of one of the Jewish
organizations in New York asked me what
what can Jews themselves do uh in order
to minimize the hostility they face I
gave him a one word answer
fail because as long as you succeed
you're going to be
hated I personally would rather succeed
and be hated than fail and be loved and
that probably is the story of the Jews
the interesting thing with Israel
related to all this is you have Jews who
are not only succeeding uh you know
they're they're struggling over this
last month obviously but you can there
is a sense I was talking to an Israeli
friend last night uh there is a sense in
the country that they are going to be
stronger than ever on the other side of
this that this is ironically bringing
them together it's it's sort of baked in
the code it's what every Jewish holiday
is about oh they killed a whole bunch of
us uh they didn't kill all of us we're
still here let's eat and Jews still are
here that is why they particularly hate
Israel because it's a place where not
only Jews are succeeding uh but then
Jews refuse to fail and they've got
weapons to make sure that that doesn't
happen so again as I keep saying and I
will keep saying you don't have to care
about the Jews I would prefer not to
have to talk about the Jews that often I
was at the debate last night where they
said Jews an awful lot and I have to
tell you it's not that great right in a
good Society right as Jordan was talking
about in a society that is robust uh you
wouldn't have to talk about the
minorities that often because things
would be basically going well and uh for
every body and that's really what
America had largely in the 80s 90s early
2000s mid 2000s it's only since we let
wokeness burst forth destroy our
institutions Crush our culture allow
literal terrorist supporters like ilhan
Omar and Rashida TB into the Democrat
Party that now this stuff is everywhere
and why is it why is it that the
mainstream media did not cover the story
of the woman in Detroit who was the
synagogue president who got killed uh
two weeks ago why is it that the main
mream media I don't think you saw it on
CNN yesterday covered the story about
the 68-year-old Jewish man who was out
there at a pro-israel rally who got hit
with a bullhorn by a Hamas supporter and
uh and he's dead now you don't know his
name Barack Obama isn't out there
talking about him because it fits when
the Jews are the victim it fits the
narrative you don't have to make a big
deal about it when the Jews are fighting
back ah this is this is the Cog uh this
is the Cog that's wrecking the rest of
the system I think you got my point uh
let me talk to you guys about Co and
then we're going to get to a community
Q&A guys if you're racking your brain
trying to think of the right present the
right present for someone you'll never
go wrong with gifting the most
comfortable sheets clothing and
accessories that your friends and family
have ever felt I'm talking about Cozy
Earth cozy Earth is just the best their
sheets are so soft and it helps me fall
asleep right away I love this stuff
actually uh you want your loved ones to
feel better sleep better and smile when
they think of you so you couldn't choose
a better gift than cozy Earth I love
their sweatpants cozy Earth is the
softest and most comfortable sheets
blankets towels PJs joggers and more
guaranteed cozy Earth only sources
premium materials like premium biscus
from bamboo giving the people on your
list super soft breathable moisture
wicking fabric regulating body
temperature and keeping them comfortable
all day and all night no matter what the
weather is whether it's their
life-changing luxury pajamas ohos soft
betting loungewear or plush bath towels
you'll love shopping and gift giving at
cozy Earth and here's my offer to you
this holiday holiday season go to Cozy
earth.com enter code Dave for to save up
to 40% that's cozy earth.com Cod Dave
cozy earth.com dve and now back to me
all right Ruben report Community Q&A and
if you want to get some questions in
we'll see if we can do one or two on the
Fly Ruben report. locals.com join right
now Bonnie says I am a pro-life person
but it seems as though Republicans are
losing at least after yesterday's
elections on the single issue of
abortion even with the economy border
violence and foreign policy issues
abortion seems to be winning elections
for Democrats how do Republicans fight
this look this one's really tough
because abortion is never going to be
settled right people have their feelings
on abortion it's not just purely a legal
issue it's a philosophical issue it's a
scientific issue right sperm meets the
egg is that the beginning of Life is
heartbeat the beginning of Life when do
you want the government to step in and
protect that life of say against the
wishes of the woman who is carrying the
child there there is so much here there
is so much here and we're never going to
get to some kind of consensus on this so
when someone tells you well I have the
answer I'm going to get you to consensus
they just don't personally as you know I
am begrudgingly pro-choice I think 12 to
15 weeks is the right number 12 weeks I
mean you're basically a couple months
into the
pregnancy um but it should be left to
the states which is why the reversal
regardless of my personal feelings on
abortion the reversal of row v Wade
kicking it back to the States so that
you can live in a place that's more in
line with your values on this and other
issues that was good your specific
question though that this seems to be a
losing thing for Republicans yeah I I
think there's every bit of evidence that
it is a losing thing for republicans and
that's probably why Virginia just lost
the house after getting a republican
Governor yunan just two years ago um it
doesn't strike me as a winner for
Republicans I think this is going to be
if if it end ends up being disantis as
the nominee which is obviously what I
think would be the best way for America
forward uh it's going to be tricky for
him because he went further to the right
than even Trump on this even though
Trump got the Supreme Court justices in
the conservative Supreme Court justices
in to reverse Roby Wade the santis has
now taken a position more to the right
he believes in the six week heartbeat
bill which is what we now have here in
Florida we had 15 weeks just a year ago
now they've changed to six but that
doesn't seem to be the place that most
of America is in now it shouldn't matter
what the president thinks on abortion
that much because it is now a state's
issue but people put abortion and this I
I discussed this with Nigel farage on
his show on on GB TV last night when
when you're thinking about what your
issues are uh right you you put
everything in a hierarchy so your issues
I think you should care mostly about
let's say the Border uh economics things
of that nature maybe foreign policy
something like that you have to figure
out which of these things are the most
important what's the most important in
everything else unfortunately many many
people have put and particularly women
of a certain age have put abortion at
the top of that thing regardless of your
feelings of abortion to me it seems like
abortion should be a little bit lower
than I don't know the borders of the
country the economic policy the foreign
policy but because so many women
specifically have put abortion up there
and it doesn't seem like a winning issue
for Republicans I don't know what
Republicans are supposed to do related
to all of this you can calmly explain
that it's a states rights issue you
could say Okay instead of abortion we'd
like to open up more clinics to help
women actually have children and then
you can uh you know put the babies up
for adoption like there there are things
that you can do but we know that the
Dems have a have a winning wedge right
here and if the Dems do one thing well
they don't they don't do a lot of things
well besides destroy things they use
their wedges wisely Alex says Gavin Nome
challenges you to a one-on-one game in
basketball are you accepting it yes
absolutely he's got a couple inches on
me how tall is Gavin Nome can I get a I
feel like he's probably he looks like
he's probably like 6'2 63 maybe but yes
I would absolutely do it we played to
that cold open yesterday where he's in
China and he grabs the basketball and
just plows through that freaking kid how
tall is he he's 63 so he's 63 I'm 511
and a halfish if we round up let's get
me to 6 foot maybe if I'm really if I'm
really you know stand it up straight
with my shoulders back we could get
there uh but yes I would I would
absolutely play that evil snake person
in one-on-one basketball uh cat says
Phoenix can you roll with me cat says so
we have so we had an early Thanksgiving
with my parents who were visiting from
out of state got me thinking about what
is one of your favorite favorite family
memories about the holiday well first
off I absolutely love Thanksgiving I
I've I've really come to love it as an
adult I've always loved Thanksgiving
like it's it really is just about food
and being around family and it's about
America and decency and like you know I
love going around the table actually
honestly my favorite thing is Probably
sounds corny like what we do for
Thanksgiving uh Thanksgiving is the the
main holiday that we host here with all
of David's family so we have about 15 or
so people around the table and just
going around the table and everyone just
saying what you're thankful for uh and
everyone does it a little bit
differently and everyone's you know
could could be Health could be family
could be the job they just got or
whatever else um but I think it's really
important to actually like sit there for
a moment if you can only do it once a
year especially if you're in America
right now while we are in this
precarious place where so much of the
goodness seems like it's like hanging on
by a thread to like sit there and and
understand what you're really
appreciative of um so I really love
doing that uh we do the uh we do the
smoked last year I did it for the first
time we've done a fried turkey a couple
times usually do the roast turkey but
last year for the first time I busted
out my big green egg we had maybe a 14
or 16 pound turkey something like that
and I smoked that maybe for probably
it's been six six or eight hours I'm not
even sure absolutely delicious we will
post some pictures in the locals
Community Larry says have you ever
designed or built a piece of furniture
out of wood I have myself but when I saw
this question right before I had Brock
take a little video of this table that's
in our studio you guys may Rec uh
recognize that table that table was
created by a uh by an artisan in Los
Angeles that was the original table that
we had in the Reuben report Studio that
was in my garage back in La years ago
can we throw the video one more time she
did something really really cool there
because you see that clear part so it's
it's uh obviously one slab and then it's
finished with resin it's absolutely I
just absolutely love that table I love
Live Edge wood in general we have some
other things in our house like that and
that is the table that we use in here
for in-person interviews uh so I I'm
very uh I'm very into woodwor in general
but I haven't done much of it myself I
should be whittling wood let's get me
whittling wood next week all right uh
Mitchell says any po interiew thoughts
Revelations on Eric Weinstein's
observation for the need to do things
differently giving the given the edge of
the cliff that we seem to be on oh you
know that's a good question and it's
it's connected to the Douglas clips that
we just showed you because if if you
haven't seen it yet I did these 20
interviews or so at ARC and Eric
Weinstein was one of them it's up right
now and he brought up the same issue
that Douglas is talking about there that
what are the limits of a liberal Society
you want to defend Free Speech you want
everyone to say what they think you want
to have protest and all of that right so
nobody's just shredding all of that but
when societies start veering towards a
place where a certain set of people are
using all of the freedoms against itself
to then turn on people the good
law-abiding citizens of those societies
on top of the fact where Europe has a
worst problem with this with all the
illegals that have come in and you just
don't know who are at these rallies and
all of the stuff uh what do you do so
that Eric and I were talking about that
like how do we sort of level up Society
how do we have a more honest
conversation about Free Speech than than
maybe we've had over the last couple
years like what are those freaking
limits and you can be angry at me if you
want but there are some of those limits
there are reasons that you cannot call
directly for violence to those people
right there say through even with the
First Amendment right you can't do that
you can't yel fire in a crowded theater
with the intent to do harm you can
actually yell fire in a theater in a in
a comedic sense or something like that
it's with the intent to do harm so we do
have some specific lanes that that allow
as much free speech as possible but now
we have people that are trying to break
those Lanes apart it's sort of like if
you had bumper
bowling you know kids have bumper
bowling right so it can't go into the
gutter we've had basic like we've
widened that lane as much as possible
and that's what you want to do in that
free Society uh but as Jordan referenced
in a robust Society these things work
but our societies don't feel very robust
right now they feel like we don't have
enough good people fighting for them so
I will continue that conversation if you
watch the whole thing with Eric we we
only had 20 minutes there uh because we
had limited studio time but I will
continue that conversation with anyone
that wants to have it what are the
mechanisms that we are going to have to
use to make sure that we don't have
people on the streets calling to kill
other people or endlessly harassing
people at their houses or places of
business again I would reference what
the santis did here in Florida changing
some laws related to property rights not
speech meaning you can't every day just
show up at someone's doorstep and put a
a flyer in their mailbox that says we
hate all Muslims or we hate all Jews
it's a property rights law not a free
speech law you want to print those
flyers and keep them around your house
or give them to your neighbors who want
them you go ahead uh you can't go across
the street from a temple and project the
digital image of a swastika on the
temple it's a property rights law not a
free speech law I've tried to explain
this to VC several times because even
last night in the debate he dishonestly
went after disantis on this but we are
going to have to figure out how to deal
with some of these things because if we
don't we will just have we will end up
with endless sectarian violence on the
streets right we'll have protesters
ruining the buildings and and blocking
traffic of certain people
counter-protesters doing on the other
side occasionally someone being hit in
the head with the megaphone and dying
and then we'll just keep doing it again
and again we got to figure this thing
out salunga says if Trump wants to seek
justice for all the lawsuits or
injustices that are happening with him
don't you think the best way he could
achieve that is if there comes a
president in 24 who can actually de
weaponize our Justice system who can
actually and meaningfully fight us from
becoming a third world country in where
politics uh in where in politics you
imprison your opponent for political
reasons yeah I think this is a great
argument for DeSantis there is no reason
to believe that he will not do what he
says Trump there is some reason to
believe that and and again the question
is if Trump became
president can he get the right people to
work around him at this point would it
be just like a revenge tour and a crazy
media tour and all of that stuff versus
could the santis come in and cleanly and
trimly look at the swamp and here's what
we're going to do to the agencies and by
the way he goes into very very minute
detail on how he would do it could he
take a guy like RFK who he has some
political differences with and task him
with taking out the CDC or in this case
deal with what's going on at the FBI or
the CIA related to the the ridiculous
prosecutions of Donald Trump yes I think
so so again we will see and I don't want
to harp on the debate last night because
I it doesn't move much right nobody I
don't think there is one person in
America you watching this right now do
you know anyone in your family friends
anyone who was like moved last night boy
you know Nikki really did get V on that
I'm voting for Nikki or just any version
of that you know I'm suddenly I heard it
and Chris Christie I'm supporting him
now nobody moves their vote on any of
that all of this is it's important to
talk about but it's relative nonsense
until polls included until we get to
that first uh that first election in
Iowa may God help us all that we get
there in the first place uh TR Hoff says
so how much fun was it to take part in
the postmodernist drinking song video
I'm glad you mentioned that we're going
to play a little clip of it so Jordan
Peterson put this thing together he
wrote this postmodernist drinking song
they did this like a year ago we shot
this and he had a whole bunch of other
people that you will recognize from the
internet I think we're going to play
like a 10 or 15 second clip of it right
now
[Music]
left yourself an absolute
mess he invented
philosophical designed to drive us
allad critical racists now Annoy Us they
accuse
[Music]
M around us
[Applause]
[Music]
time Jordan's working hard you know the
man's doing a lot of different stuff uh
it was totally fun to do that Daphne my
assistant was in studio that day she's a
she was a theater chick back in the day
she gave me a little Direction on the
singing so there's just a couple little
Clips maybe maybe in some alternate
universe we'll re will'll reveal the
full like 10minute thing of me singing
that thing alone it was not really my
main skill set uh but it was totally fun
the full thing on that you can find at
Jordan's YouTube channel I'm sure Amy
says when you moov to Miami what was the
hardest thing to do find a good doctor
dentist or hair stylist that is a great
question because I have to say you guys
know I love Florida I love Miami I have
I really have no complaints about this
place it is just so great freedom is
flourishing I love the weather I love
the people I love the lizards all of the
stuff my one it's not even a complaint
it's like under complaint uh would be
that finding certain service providers
like doctors or or good electricians
that kind of stuff has been a little bit
tricky in Miami it's partly because so
many people are moving here that you
just can't get appointments that quickly
uh my dentist seems to be
fine dentist seems to be fine my hair
stylist I have to say my hair is looking
pretty damn good these days my hair
stylist is Phoenix's f
Fon but I shouldn't say her name right
we don't want her to be harassed uh but
if you want to know if you know what if
you're watching in locals and you want
to know where I get my haircut and you
want to visit her in Miami you'll let me
know over there I'll let you know who
she is and she's just fantastic and uh a
regular
doctor went
once sort of indifferent uh but yeah
that is one of the functions of success
right most of the most of whatever the
issues are that Florida is having like
High house prices are functions of
success because more and more people
keep coming here last night driving to
the uh to the debate which was in Bickle
that's the like the city part of Miami
that's like the city city part of it um
there's a lot of traffic because a lot
of people are moving here but what's
nice about it you see them building
roads you're driving on the traffic
roads and they're building roads above
you so they're doing everything they
absolutely can here and I would rather
frankly live in a place that the the
problems are because of success right
the problems are like oh man so many
freaking people are coming here there's
so much New Economic value here there
are so many new and by the way people
coming and voting the right way that's
way better than when you're on the other
side of things say when you're walking
around in San Francisco and you're like
oh that door closed that store closed oh
look at that crackhead oh there's a dead
man over there etc etc uh Jeff says how
do we improve voter eligibility
verification the public needs to be
educated about the actual election
ballot counting process I think most
people do not know how votes are
actually counted for instance where I to
where I to run a stack of ballots
through a machine take the same stack
change a few Shuffle and repeat what
prevents the essentially same stack from
being overcounted over and over yeah
yeah without getting into that specific
thing about the
stacks election verification making sure
one person one vote you have an
ID you walk in as I did in Florida when
I have voted you walk in you show them
your ID they look at you on a list they
verify it's you you vote you then take a
piece of paper you put it in a box or in
a folder or whatever it might be and
that that that process just just the
process of doing that gives you faith
that the system is working now that
doesn't mean that there can't be other
little questions or anything else but
you know I've had uh cord berdon who is
the Secretary of State of Florida if you
haven't seen that we did it maybe six
months ago or so and we most of the
interview we talked about election
Integrity which nobody even the crazy
people who rant and Rave about Florida
all day nobody legit is questioning
whether Florida is running legitimate
elections or not like we have the
tightest cleanest elections that is in
stark contrast to Los Angeles where not
only do you not have to have an ID if
you try to show them their ID which I
tried to do when I voted in the recall
to get rid of Nome and I was Voting
obviously for Larry Elder and my by
default you walk into a an election uh
area you your my hand just went to my
wallet like oh I'm supposed to show
these people who I am that's the way it
always was since I've been voting at my
elementary school back in whatever the
first year I could vote around ' 96
something like that
9094 um I went to show the guy my ID and
he kind of recoiled like this that and
that tells
you when they constantly tell you when
they constantly tell you oh my God if we
have voter IDs black people won't be
allowed to vote they won't be able to
vote show me a black person that doesn't
have an ID you need an ID to get on a
plane are black people on planes have
any of you seen black people on
I saw Snakes on a Plane anyone you saw
all right Conor saw a black guy on a
plane once black people can get IDs
Asian people can get IDs the only reason
you would not want people to have IDs to
vote is if you wanted to rig the system
or you wanted questions about the system
to exist so that you could eventually
burn down the system and that's exactly
what the Dems want uh Jay says I do have
a question about locals Rumble and X Etc
I see more collaboration between the
three platforms happening via Rumble is
there locals app for Roku Etc in the
works there is a rumble app for Roku uh
which we're trying we're working on a
lot of integration behind the scenes
right now everything takes a little bit
of time uh that will include locals
within that I don't know that we're
doing a standalone Roku app I will get
back to you on that I will post
something in the in the community for
sure but yes the ecosystem around Free
Speech online it basically starts with
Rumble X locals and then there's
obviously a couple other little things
but we are the places believe me there
are plenty of people right now who have
locals communities who do not like Dave
Rubin and that is just fine there are
plenty of people we have several fairly
bigname people who are in my estimation
anti-israel nutbags who have locals
communities and are on Rumble and
everything else I believed in building
something that would allow people to say
whatever they want to say again within
within the laws because if you break the
laws of the United States you have a
much bigger problem than what locals is
going to do to you or what Rumble is
going to do to so we are doing
everything we can and that would also
get us back to to what Douglas talked
about before about the limits of
liberalism and what Eric and I were
talking about in that chat about how do
we level up this conversation so you
don't have constantly people people
rigging the system you know one of the
other things that elon's going to have
to deal with on Twitter because I'm
seeing this more than ever now and I've
been on Twitter for a long time and
spent way too much of my uh life force
on that godforsaken platform uh there
are more Bots and trolls on there than
ever is just completely run rampant so
we have algorithmic tricks trying to
confuse people you know one of the
things they can do one of the ways they
can manipulate you it's not just they
can say on YouTube that through your
feed they can manipulate what you see
right so you search something they can
manipulate you to see you know you could
search literally anything right and they
can figure out ways to make you think
one thing or another related to whatever
it is that you searched the other thing
that they can do and I'm seeing this
more and more on Twitter right now and
people should just be aware of it is
when I post anything I I get a gajillion
and they're all Anonymous accounts
they're all basically created in the
last two or three months putting all
sorts of pramas propaganda up there and
they're putting Hitler pictures and blah
blah blah so you could by creating it a
a the facade that all of these people
are for this cause you could make it
seem like that cause is just so there is
a absolute information a matrix style
information war going on and you just
have to you have just have to know you
have to know that it exists and then you
have to figure out what your role is
going to be in that are you going to
participate on these platforms or
anything else I really think honestly
it's the it's the beauty of what we did
with locals by just anyone can join for
free and look at stuff but to get in to
ask me questions here to comment to be
part of our live chats and everything
else we ask you for a couple bucks and
through asking for a couple
bucks it cleans up almost all of it and
that's also why now that we're doing
this live calling show which we're doing
every day from one to uh from 1 p.m. uh
on Mondays through Thursdays it's like
I'm choosing people out of there cuz you
can basically eliminate all the trolls
and the Bots and the Bad actors so a
little skin in the game goes a long way
Kevin says what's your go-to seasoning
for brisket or pakana pakana you know I
am digging some pakana lately have you
done the pakana over yet you're doing
the Pana once so picana is an
interesting cut of meat because you're
getting basically it sort of looks like
brisket but then you get this very thick
fat cap on top so what you do with the
bana is you put in the fridge for a
while so the fat is kind of it's not so
gelatinous it's kind of like a little
bit thicker then you score it so like
little X's across my seasoning go-to I
am a firm believer that B on almost
everything just good salt and pepper is
pretty much all you need but if you
score that thing right so then the fat
will start dripping actually dripping
into it as you cook and there's always a
debate with pakana do you cook it fat
side up or fat side down I believe in
fat side up because then the fat
actually is kind of coalescing around
the meat while you're I I like to smoke
them but you can you can bake it or you
can roast it whatever but coarse salt
and pepper is the secret to Dave rubin's
steak and Adam Corolla is one of many
people who said that the best steak he
ever had in his entire life was a wagu
tomahawk that Dave Rubin made back in La
just saying uh but yeah course that
thing salt and pepper you could do a
little bit of a little you could do some
onion powder some garlic powder uh
sometimes I'll do some paprika things
like that but I think if you have a good
cut of meat salt and pepper is all you
need Mary says my thoughts on the
ability of Facebook to Monitor and
censor almost in real time political
conservative post videos Etc contrasted
with their failure to stop live streams
and uploads of murdered to victim
profiles I think Mark Zuckerberg will
have a lot to answer for I might have
read that in in a little bit of an odd
way but basically yes we know the
conservatives are being uh censored
hunted down on these platforms and then
we know I mean think about how twist
there's so many stories and they're
still coming out right now how twisted
everything that happened on uh October
7th was but then these people these
Hamas terrorists they literally took the
phones of the victims and they live
streamed their murders and rapes and
burning bodies and and all of the
horrors they live streamed it to
Facebook they live streamed it to
Whatsapp they posted images in telegram
so that the family members would see
these things um man these these Tech
platforms and and I have a little
insight into this through what we're
doing with Rumble and locals you there's
a lot of stuff that you got to work on
to figure out what are the best ways
again to protect Free Speech have basic
protections make sure that your
platforms are not being manipulated by
Bots and trolls and all of those things
um but I would say
largely especially as we roll into this
election year do not think that Facebook
is ever going to correct itself do not
think that Google is going to course
correct right um they just are not we
know they're not Twitter before Elon was
censoring the hunter Biden laptop story
Twitter has course corrected right
Twitter is absolutely not perfect for
sure right and you guys can have
whatever criticism you have of rumble or
anything else um so there probably is no
perfect system right it's tough for
imperfect humans to create perfect
systems that's kind of baked into the
the whole thing um but don't think for
one second that Tick Tock is going to
course correct or any of these things
they have made their choice they they
throw some crumbs to the conservatives
every now and again and by the way you
know i' I've had my frustrations with v
but he made a great point last night
when he opened up the debate basically
saying hey look how farcical this whole
thing is we're up here with in essence
Democrat activists right we're up here
with Democrats basically questioning us
but if it was a Democrat debate they'd
never bring on Fox News guys or Greg
Gutfeld to grill them and that's the
same thing with big Tech the asymmetry
of the thing is is really what the
problem is Alvaro says hey Dave why do
you say you'll still vote for Trump if
he is the nominee your coverage of him
recently is negative wouldn't that be
hypocritical well look you you you vote
for what you got at the end of the day
and if the choic is I still do not think
Biden will be the nominee I said it the
day he was sworn into office but if
Biden is the nominee there's no doubt
that Trump would be better it's just
there's just no doubt like if I was just
to look at all the things that I care
about and everything else uh Trump
especially pre-o was doing a lot of the
right stuff the economy was chugging
along a lot of Peace deals in the Middle
East like yes the media was apoplectic
and all of that stuff he failed us on
coid unfortunately and I think
subsequently the way he's run this
campaign has not been good but he would
be a far better president than Joe Biden
he obvious I have to say anything about
Gavin Nome he would be better than
Camala Harris and everything else the
thing is in politics you usually don't
get that many great people I think it's
the next it's the next real issue we
have to think about if this thing
doesn't work out for disantis I look you
can say whatever you want about the
antis and that look when he does these
debates does he ever have the ultimate
Zinger moment is he the most Free Will
and standup guy up there like fully in
the moment doing his thing no he's he's
more prepackaged and all that stuff so
he has his limitations but in terms of
policy in terms of 45-year-old three kid
Good Wife good family doing the right
thing great track record it's like I
don't know that it's ever going to get
better than him that would be my
estimation like I don't mean that in
like a worship kind of way I mean it in
here's someone doing what we all ask of
our public servants and Trump has
basically tried to annihilate the guy
and when we get on the other side of
whatever this election is you watching
this right now why aren't you in
politics why am I not in politics
because who would want to put them
through that thing who wants to be just
thrown in to the Sharks right or the
Gators as it were or whatever nobody
wants that and we will ultimately we
will just keep getting what we deserve
we'll have worse and worse people who
will run so anyway yes I will definitely
support Trump if he doesn't if if it's
not the santis the the Democrats have
lost the plot altogether so it just kind
of is what it is Sarah says if Dan
santis doesn't win the nomination and
Trump does do you think DeSantis could
play an important role in helping get
Trump elected and also may be working
with him uh in the administration if he
assuming he wins look DeSantis I have no
doubt if Trump is the nominee DeSantis
will fight for him Dan santis loves this
country and I know he knows that Trump
would put it better on track than the
Democrats would it's in essence it's
what I just said right there the reverse
of that though is a little more
confusing if Dan santis got the
nomination I don't know that Trump would
push Maga towards him I think he would
say they stole it from me first it was
the Democrats and it was the machine and
and now it's Des Santos stealing it from
me and that's been the danger that's
been you know I've called it a dark
force that Trump has used for quite some
time that's been the danger there if if
you knowingly lie about the guy who we
all thought was the best governor in
America 6 months ago like if you took
the top top 10 most rabid Trump
supporters big account Trump supporters
on Twitter that hate Dan santis now they
all loved him 6 months ago right they've
all deleted all the tweets but everyone
knew he was the guy and Trump used a
very dark force to basically make a
bunch of people who love this guy now
hate him and once you use that dark
force I don't know how you put that back
in right it's Pandora's Box you've
opened up something how do you then say
Oh you know the guy who I said was
working with Soros even though santis is
the one guy to fire Soros da the guy who
I said is Paul Ryan's friend and loves
Carl Ro and all like all lies the guy
who was bad on Co like again all lies
like but you've convinced a lot of
people of that you'd have to have a Maya
cple yourself and that that is not
really within Trump's skill set I don't
think but again we we'll see what
happens one more for you Ted says what
inspired you to do the call-in show with
community members uh you know I have
wanted to do a call-in show
probably probably before any of these
guys even worked for me I mean probably
like six seven years I just always loved
Old School radio you know my first real
gig in media I had a show on SiriusXM
radio and we used to take calls live and
you know we'd get a queue of callers and
the the director or the producer would
look through the calls screen them
basically and you just never know what's
going to happen and I've always just
loved that so I've wanted to do it for a
long time uh David saaks who's been on
the show a couple times he created the
call-in app which eventually Rumble
purchased and now we are we're
reconfiguring to become the Rumble
studio app and that's what we're running
the so that's the software that we run
it on so you guys so we can take your
calls so I was waiting for the last year
I wanted to do it on Colin but because
of locals I didn't want to send you guys
to a new app so once we acquired the
company I was like guys please make this
happen ASAP and the team is working real
hard and we've now integrated it so
Rumble Studio this is a little under the
hood stuff for you is what we're running
it on and it's really really great and
we're bringing in a whole bunch of new
features over the next couple months so
I was waiting sort for the tech on it uh
and then tenant media came to me and
they said basically hey we'd like to
give you some money to do whatever the
hell you want to do and I was like oh
well I've wanted to do this thing and I
need some money to do it and this all
kind of works and and it just came out
uh it came out perfectly and I've really
been loving it and I'm doing it with
Isabelle Brown in case you guys haven't
tuned in yet who I've also wanted to
work with for for quite some time so
it's really been nice so far and you can
watch us in uh what about an hour and 7
Minutes uh right here on my Rumble
Channel or on the tenant channels acoss
the interwebs uh my full interview guys
of a former house Speaker Kevin McCarthy
he was over in London at uh at ARC that
is up right now and we've got a postgame
show for you at Ruben report. locals.com
I Leave You with video of gay Pete and
Mr zalinsky from Ukraine I think this
might be edited I don't want to get us
in any sort of trouble I think there
might be a little bit of editing
trickery here
goodbye thank you thank you thank you so
much you're having us over where's my
money to see good so far very good
[Music]
business